SUBJECT 1: I've been called
the supermodel of hands.
I think it's because I've had
the longest career of any hand
model out there.
In those little
seven inches, I have
to convey a whole feeling, a
whole story, a whole thought
process about what's going
into that advertising campaign.
I wear gloves quite
often, especially when
I'm outside, to protect
my hands from the elements
and from the things
that can happen.
But I take really
good care of them.
And you'll see why
I'm a hand model,
because I have flawless
skin and nice long nails,
and very graceful hands.
And that's really
become my signature.
I never know when I'm going
to have a hand modeling job.
So I could get
called now and have
to be somewhere in an
hour, so my hands always
have to be ready to go.
I have lots of polishes that
I bring around every job, just
the basics.
I bring sunglasses,
because a lot
of times you're under
really hot light,
so you have to
protect your eyes.
I'm the first to joke about it.
Like, I wear gloves.
I go out to the bar.
I can completely make fun of
my life, because everybody just
makes fun of me all
the time pretty much.
It is a fun job to be silly
about, but you know what?
I am the most serious
about what I do,
and I am the most
professional person.
Hand modeling is
incredibly competitive.
So that means if
I have a paper cut
and the next hand model
doesn't have a paper cut
and they don't have to pay the
expense of having Photoshop,
they're not going to choose me.
So I always just
have to be perfect.
And you can't have a lot
of ego involved with it,
because we audition a
lot and sometimes people
reject your hands.
So there's two very
different ways of working.
One is for print, where
we're working with a camera
and it's stills.
So that means having my
hands look the most graceful
and support the product in the
best way they possibly can.
If you're on TV or video,
it's a whole different set
of techniques.
That's all about hitting a
mark and doing a movement,
and being able to recreate that
movement time and time again.
I love to do both.
And I've really created
a technique around it,
so now I actually teach it.
And there was never
someone to teach me,
and I'm really glad that
I can teach other people
this very unique
thing that really
only I can teach, in a sense.
I think hand modeling
is really my dream job.
I get to be a performer, and
yet I run my own business.
I've done this for
a really long time,
so my hands look like
they're in their 20s.
But I'm really not, obviously.
But I've been able to parlay
this into a nice long career,
much longer than most
models are able to do.
So I feel like I can really
age gracefully into this career
well into my 90s.
NARRATOR: To learn about another
fun way to make a living,
check out this next video about
a scientist who climbs trees.
SUBJECT 2: The most
common reaction
I get when I'm on a flight
sitting next to somebody
and they ask what do I
do, and I tell them I
study sleeping sloths
and I climb trees,
they think it's a joke.
And then I tell them
no, I'm serious,
and I show them
pictures on my phone,
and they're like, that is the
coolest job I've ever heard of,
and how is that really a job?
And how do I get to do that?
NARRATOR: Thanks for
watching, and please
subscribe to Seeker Stories
for new videos every week.